peu
[Musique]
le réveil matin et tout me revient
je lève je laime joubran la radio par an
ou deux mots j'aimerais qu'on le dise
ils l'aiment qu'il aime je mets ma
chemise un coup de peigne
je bois mon café de sucre à peine et mes
pensées sans doute les mêmes cette
instance
genève genève qui m'arrive
je descends dans la rue j'en prends
l'avenue toujours la même feuille rouge
combien les gens m'ont derrière déjà le
feu vert avenue du maine comme un
automate je tourne à droite
déjà les problèmes la ville et coucy
jeune acrobate ou suis je fou mais
dis-moi du marionnettiste
[Musique]
depuis seuls
hautmont
elle
je veux faire
un tour de paix
mais où je voulais
non sourire
les droits
moi
mon coeur
soudain c'est tout
que feras tu
gentil
[Musique]
fait
je revois la selle exactement avant-hier
elle est entrée au restaurant puis s'est
assise devant moi d'un coup j'ai compris
que dans ma vie j'avais dons
depuis 30 ans est foudroyé par se
connaître je suis tombé dans sa lumière
comme une course au corps à corps elle
n'a qu'un seul mot
encore encore elle n'a qu'un seul pays
d'abord il n'a plus qu'un corps
aussi et par la fenêtre je vois paris
j'ai rêvé peut-être trop j'ai dormi et
tout d'un coup je vis
q
[Musique]
de 6 heures
hautmont
tout le fun
un pur
mais où je vais je n'en
on se
le dis moi tu
[Musique]
le disent tout
mon coeur de
soudan
que 28
raison
après la fête
mais dans l'ascenseur connu moncler
salle et je vois un bon pour moi tu dis
oublie moi qui nous supprime maintenant
ça va mieux pour tous les deux chacun
son chemin même si l'été reste chacun
vend chèvre accuse la stibus était sur
le trottoir mauvais comme ça mais dans
les branches entre de chez moi
maréchal pense au bar tabac je prends un
café des sols
on n'oublie jamais
le cumul j'aimerais
et toutes les parts du une voile à
méditer bout
dix mois
de 6e
2 tu me fais faire
le
tour de piste
j'ouvrais
je n'en sais rien
mais dis moi
non
mais tu
une corde
que fais-tu non
les artistes
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]